thank you
[Music]
welcome to another great episode of
careful boys we have with us today
Colleen Lionheart
I wanted to know since we're of the
generation where we were not entirely
Born Into the internet the attitude I
kind of had to figure it out as we were
growing up we you know 56k mash it was
rough we were having and experiencing
the most unsupervised internet usage
days that were possible hey uh very very
little ways to hide anything you were
doing as well as a very little reason
parents even gave a [ __ ] about what you
were looking at so during that time when
you were a kid did you ever make friends
with people online that you never
actually met in real life yep yes
where
uh I don't know where
but uh
but I would usually troll all the time
and pretend like I'm like a 15 year old
girl and then I would try to like seduce
dudes
and then what's the legend dude somehow
I ended up talking I found out I was
talking to a chick
who's really Joe on the other side
and then we started like talking and
then I think through our conversation we
realized oh [ __ ] like she's in Anaheim
and I'm in Cerritos just kind of close
wow and then it went from there to on
the phone
and then uh we really and then we
started realizing some of our friends
probably go to the same church or
whatever
and no they know it's crazy but I don't
know what happened from that point oh
you didn't get like touch I mean she was
a real girl right you talked her on the
phone yeah a lot of times unless I don't
know there's some crazy technology it's
like a muscles like Manti Teo yeah yeah
yeah or even the FBI [ __ ] dropped the
ball it was a real girl
and you never met that's pretty cool
you're the only guy I've ever met who
actually met a real girl this was like
Jewel your [ __ ] luck is insane trying
to be a part 1998 baby wow yeah it's
like back in the day the cool thing is
back then like I know now there's a
stigma about like meeting people online
might be creepy whatever back then it
was cool because you know there were
very little stories like you didn't hear
a lot of bad [ __ ] we didn't know how
weird it was yet no not at all like you
could just go on prodigy or copy server
whatever everything was just about
meeting people just saying random [ __ ]
and tripping out that someone talked
back yeah ASL you're a real person
you're on a computer and it's like whoa
you're a real person and then you start
connecting with like-minded people I
remember like in Early College where
it's still kind of weird or you've met
people online but there's like forums
was like a big thing
and then my buddies that were into like
[ __ ] reptiles and like fishes and
stuff
they would start they're like hey you in
the world because I was a guy I was
always the guy with the truck so you
just become the automatic help me move
[ __ ] guy yeah so it's like hey can you
can you help me we're gonna go [ __ ]
pick up his fish tank or whatever and
then I'm like because all I don't know
this guy's cool and we show up to
people's houses don't worry he's a
lizard guy
he thinks of random things
piranhas and like
and like you're just like what the [ __ ]
and I'm like man it's like a whole
nother side to my friend that I never
knew I mean so this is what you're doing
when you're [ __ ] lurking around
online this [ __ ] talking to other
reptile people so you're not describing
Joe no this was uh one of my other
buddies I feel like a lot of these
stories I'm like it could be Joe yeah so
that's Sancho it could be Joe I mean Joe
probably sold those things he's showing
piranhas at the time my other friend was
more of a customer as a buyer you like
he liked those things you want to bought
from Joe so in terms of people that um
meeting online that I did meet there was
one dude back in the day in early 90s
AOL
um you would have to go into chat rooms
and the different chat rooms if you went
to the Asian tab would be like split up
by what type of Asian it would be Pinoy
panai there would be like Cambodian
there'd be like all this stuff and you
just go in and talk to people and then
what we used to do in the Pinoy Pinay
chat room is we would uh raid other
culture chat rooms and just talk [ __ ]
for no reason
we would go into the uh cambodians chat
room and just keep typing Cambo soup
Campbell Soup like over and over so they
couldn't believe and then we would do
these macro images where they were like
dashes and stuff but it would make the
Campbell Soup can all right and then it
would just take up the whole page and
then we would just piss them off like
crazy because before they couldn't even
reply anything like oh yeah it's like
dude
baby just [ __ ] their chat to death and
they would all leave and they would be
like
so back in the day for no reason for
absolutely no reason Filipinos just were
beefing with the cambodians for zero
reason and that was just because of you
used we would do back and forth it was
kind of like a lightheart joke and then
the guys that would do that with I was
like dude this is fun like you're
actually really cool and stuff and then
I found out uh later on that that dude
was also like got into breaking at the
same time no way and then I would see
him in the b-boy Pinoy Pinoy chats and
I'd be like yo this is tight oh [ __ ]
yeah and then uh later on he ended up uh
I would run into him from time to time
in my life in different real life
scenarios in person yeah so it turned
out later like one of the guys that did
my crew his name's Rudy he's actually
cousins with that [ __ ] guy no way and
then now today like uh we were talking
the other uh month about hollow hollow
ice cream and the hollow hollow ice
cream place got tagged in the comments
like you should try this place turns out
he's the [ __ ] owner no way this guy
keeps popping up in your life crazy is
that yeah to marry this guy or something
yeah so what was born out of Cambodian
hate is now a nice little princess
that's crazy and here's a really
interesting story about people I'd never
met this is gonna be really [ __ ]
weird so another uh subchat in AOL at
the time it was called Dr game whiz
doctor game was was not only a chat room
but it was like a little it was aol's
only gaming section that was just all
about video game stuff you can go get
codes for games you can get strategy
guides it was called doctor game ways
okay in the chat room there was one
doctor game was who's probably the owner
of that little subset thing that was
sanctioned by AOL so you can't just make
your own doctor games so this guy would
talk to people like hey welcome to the
chat if you guys have any questions
whatever I thought that was so cool I
was a kid at the time maybe like I was
probably in eighth grade
I thought it'd be cool to make an AOL
name called game whiz Junior and I was
going to act like I was affiliated with
the chat but I acted like a robot so I
used those alt fonts where you could
just make weird symbols like wean dings
yeah like weird things that you normally
people didn't know how to like color
your font like if you hold alt and you
say oh one three four let go it would be
like a cross that you can't normally
type so I would like do these weird
symbols to make it look like I'm a bot
which they didn't have at the time and I
would be like welcome to the chat I am
your Bot game whiz Junior and people
would ask for codes for games and I
would just look them up at some other
source because I had stacks of gaming
magazines and I would tell them the
codes they wanted to know as if it was
an auto response and people were
freaking out they would go there's a
[ __ ] automatic robot giving us the
codes to the things we're asking for
sure and I did this for a year straight
a very helpful tool yeah dude yeah were
you like a Good Samaritan and then at
one point I [ __ ] up and I did the alt
code wrong and one of the symbols was
off and it started this huge like
conspiracy of like I think game was
junior is a real guy you noticed that he
did this symbol wrong right here and all
this whole chat of like 100 kids were
like I think he might be a real guy it
was a real thing and I got so
embarrassed that I left the chat
so they [ __ ] themselves out on all
these cheat codes they had it for like a
couple hours that's the most internet
thing ever we have to call out something
that doesn't [ __ ] matter and then you
ruin the whole fun of it yeah and then
game whiz Junior jumps off a [ __ ]
cliff yeah let everybody down I remember
I remember one time I turned in uh one
of my my fifth grade or sixth grade like
homework assignments All In wingdings
wow that's also the most bar thing I
actually wrote the paper but then you
know how like you're like messing with
fonts you highlight the whole thing and
I was like
oh what it's [ __ ] butterflies and
zippers and [ __ ] like that oh my God
you thought that this is just to be
funny yeah I got in trouble
they did say like
and they had they created the the new
rule like Times New Roman 10 or 8.
he standardized the policy for essay
turns because teacher went through a box
of red pens trying to correct your paper
no this kid hasn't happened to me again
it's all the yin yang symbols yeah yeah
teachers like hurting their cramping
their hand because they're doing so many
[ __ ] red markers
teachers got a [ __ ] re-fucking type
in in wingdings font and translate it to
figure out what you said yeah you ever
meet any girls online
I don't know I I think I always like
randomly would chat and ran things like
that like just uh genres of things but I
was always I didn't know who I was
talking to so I didn't ever really
pursue deeply and then I always had very
limited amounts of Internet time and
then my sister got it because she's the
older sister yeah so I always got
[ __ ] what felt like 10 of the time
that she got because she was older what
about doing the whole like aim era did
you were you able to like by that time I
was talking to friends already oh yeah
it was just like you know when I wasn't
like trying to meet new people through I
am I was trying to like get chicks aims
at my school you know what I mean and
like just kind of be in like those
groups classic Anthony but maybe it's
also because I'm like younger than you
guys about a couple years right so it's
like uh by that time people started like
having their aim identity and like being
able to talk about that versus like your
identity you're hiding behind your
identity and you're just in chat rooms
not knowing who people are yeah by the
time you're like handing them out and
trying to meet people with this like
digital username you know does anybody
else remember their username their aim
username absolutely yeah a lot of weird
chats I had like XPO folks X I'd like
64. I mean like like poor folks okay so
there's this [ __ ] in Buena Park on
[ __ ] uh be sure if there's a Po Folks
restaurant do you remember this why are
you repping it
I don't know I just thought it was
[ __ ] funny I ate there one time like
it looks out the window I ate that one
time and I was like it's all right but
then it's like Po Folks and I like it
that much I was like my parents are poor
or what kind of food is like Cajun
literally thought I was like my parents
are poor Po Folks is like poor [ __ ]
parents and I was like that's me wow you
identified me you thought it was funny
hello folks yeah
yeah [ __ ] break but I really did I
was like my parents are poor so my old
screen name was silly goose but the
second o was a zero see did he identify
with a goose but that's like Asian
gangsters that time had names like that
though
Bert Swan and the goose that's
interesting some of the scariest Asian
thugs I met had names like that in real
[ __ ] life they like there were some
gangs that were like yo what gang you oh
Teddy Ruxpin gang Teddy Ruxpin and they
look [ __ ] fiercely I heard to say the
silly goose gang yeah like there were
people like one of my friends uh older
cousins was a uh like a two-time cop
killer already so yeah metaphor so he's
one of those dudes where like if if like
they pulled him over uh if cops pulled
them over and then they like they ran
whatever his information they would
shoot him on the spot like they wouldn't
even like put him in jail or whatever
they're like okay this is for killing
like our our brothers like you like I
don't care what it is if we find so he's
one of those guys where he's like he's
so on the verge of either getting like
exported back to Vietnam or [ __ ]
thrown in jail for life that he was just
down for anything because he's so
[ __ ] crazy because he's on that edge
you know like it doesn't matter where he
goes it's gonna be the worst sentence
ever and his name was muffin
you look the craziest [ __ ] this
one his name is muffin yeah he was loved
at one point yeah I guess I don't know
how did he just get muffin it was just
so you get a name like that well it's
because the way he had his hair so he
had slick back hair and I guess the way
he faded it it always poured over a
little like a muffin top so muffin
became his thing but then he's like this
crazy ass [ __ ] just named muffin
dude scary yeah
there were a lot of gangsters like that
in chat rooms too they had like gangster
chat rooms on AOL I guess the island
isn't that funny yeah pretty much like
all the Asian Thug dudes and they would
put their gang in their screen name
and I had my [ __ ] Team Fortress
classic clan in my streaming we were
5150 they're criminally insane because
like when you're a kid you find out
about that and you're like oh yeah we're
thinking so then that was our plan crazy
5150 and then we played Team Fortress
classic and beat up on these other teams
and [ __ ] but those are the guys I knew
but I never met him but then like I
everyone called me snake because I like
Metal Gear Solid so it was like call me
snake
like I whisper it too yeah you never try
to meet up with any of them like No And
if you guys are in San Diego or uh I I
don't I there was no reason to it was
like we played games online we played
this one game online and we played it
really [ __ ] well and and that was the
only reason I had to even talk to them
really like outside of like my normal
friend group oh I recently met um I
totally forgot for like six four to six
years I've been playing GTA online with
a friend that lived in the Netherlands
that I just met like randomly online and
we've just been playing GTA like uh with
a group of like 12 of us sometimes and
then uh I met her recently when I was in
Amsterdam for the first time oh cool
yeah it was dope did she look like what
she thought he pictured in her head yeah
like a [ __ ] Netherland person how
does it feel like meeting interest
meeting someone that you've known
without I think it's I think it's
different because nowadays games are
different than it would have been back
then where like back then it was so much
about the game and then now it's so much
more about the social so like we know so
much about each other's lives from just
playing and talking for hours it's
really like therapeutic in a way yeah
and so like meeting in person is really
just like meeting a close friend for the
first time like that's the opposite of
meeting like family you know like my
mom's like this your cousin you guys are
best friends I'm like no I don't know
who the [ __ ] he is is
[Laughter]
exactly the opposite of that yeah well I
don't know where the [ __ ] they I don't
give a [ __ ] about the same blood doesn't
mean [ __ ]
[Music]
foreign